prendo tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono famiglie ed oggi siamo
su
chase inter ma io ho visto la intro
classifica e nei video mai tu che
assistiamo successi dance che questo
gioco dove si struscia la gente sui
metri dietro
[Musica]
non ho capito il senso come mission e
poi però fosse un gioco nello spazio
invece la prima missione 955 mila 600
miglia
la seconda è pripria la terza e
afghanistan
c'è un krhin e chernobyl e allora che
cazzo c'entrano gli zombie che si
strusciano non ho capito se come stai
ziata posto barca la [ __ ] che boccia
ragazzi c'è una tipa che parla e mezza
nuda e pensa che io possa prestare
attenzione se una ragazza è vestita così
e mi parla io non guardo negli occhi è
impossibile la rai è sparita offesa mi
spiace non volevo perché sto andando
sulla terra siamo su una navicella
ragazzi non sono anche come né perché
questo è il continuo di star wars
ragazzi questa è
il millennium falcon 2.0 io sono fa
ejeie che si schianta sul piano favario
ne terro in giovino aspetta non
rispondono i comandi siamo nella cacca e
ci siamo a schiantarsi a dada almeno una
dritta su stile non so pilota gas non ci
manca patente la sua pure pelato che fin
tutte io a chi sei e gettato che cosa
succede se va bene ma che cazzo di sfiga
de merda vero è passato un aeroplano
mentre stavo cadendo giù ma vi sembra
possibile
e poi ci sono entrato senza morire va
bene ma devo muovere [ __ ] [ __ ] para
ma si coglieva che spara verso zombie
tutti ma io devo muovermi prima che lei
rossi schianti salve comandiamo è bella
lì e mi spiace che vi faccia la vostra
conoscenza così ma se voi non ti uccido
scusatemi qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegarmi perché ci sono degli zombie
probabilmente la tipa lo stava spiegando
perché non lo caga tali striscio e ci
sarà un motivo a bella del sì che vuoi
fare c'è il fascino della gnocca ti
giuro che non volevo sbagliato tasso
stiamo andando la madonna carpisa fatta
per chi viaggia in sicurezza fatti ea
stai zitta brutta [ __ ] appunto parli
porca [ __ ] ma perché con spuntano gli
zombie cosa sta succedendo reagan sei
ragazzi io sto andando avanti a caso ha
uccidere gente senza motivo però ma ero
cos'è cazzo the walking dead aiuto a
[ __ ] ragazzi dobbiamo muovere il
culetto prima che assieme a 18 piedi da
terra
intanto la ero di cascami
che gioco della madonna lega m 15 cm 15
uccidi il pilota mutante più mutante di
questo quale si è incastrato nel
pavimento non lo so zio [ __ ] mastronzo
c'è un tipo invisibile tipo predator che
sparì ciao raga non ho capito un cazzo
perché c'è un pilota mutante dove astra
ecco ecco la co e non muore e che devo
fare
minchia che mira che ciò incredibile non
datemi ma in arma ragazzi su come la
madonna che chat tutte lui le biglie al
culo e molto veloce
c'è la [ __ ] non mi distrarre [ __ ] in un
moto perfetto al ride open cockpit
non so che cosa voglia dire cockpit non
sembra una parola porno dove cazzo è il
piani sopra l'ho perso ben trenta
secondi c'è una valigia di medda e zio
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dieci
secondi però ci sono il cockpit
no non lo zio cosa cazzo fai questo è
scemo la zia non hai le ali si è buttato
mi spiace gioca non posso dartelo perché
sono e morirò presto ma chi cazzo è
questa vi traduco io ragazzi oddio fa
vigenti mi dispiace che ti stai andando
a schiantare sapevo che eri ben dotato è
una gran perdita per tutti noi ma io
c'ho questo nigger che può soddisfarmi
questo sta dicendo non ho capito il
senso
addio son tornati qui con calma audio
c'è un paracadute si è aperto il park
era quindi ce l'aveva il paracadute dove
siamo
che cos'è sta roba oddio mi dispiace
insieme sarà le bocce della tizia che
fungono talmente tanto da airbag che mi
funzionano anche se in videochiamata
premi per avviare un film a si guarda
che c'è stata una tara girati vi è un
bel film c'è anche un figo che sta
parlando di suwayda mascotte zia e
madonna mi chiamava fatelo giocare in
nazionale statista tira dei calci
incredibili questo ne corre anzi è
sempre ancora di come pingu te lo dico
io
e muori come pingue permesso sono fa vj
deve andare al traguardo e tanto che
bella giornata
salve è bella giornata vero ragazzi
cazzo vi abbia via via via veloce veloce
non c'è e va bene minchia entra oddio
oddio e non si apre rapporto che si
aperto ce l'ho fatta ragazzi non so come
faccio adesso riuscito ancora non hai
capito che come non ci puoi parlarci e
comunque sia ucciso il nika che stava
dietro di me così me lo puoi buttare
sala talk e romantica che questa ragazza
90 gentile perché non esiste questo
tasto nella vita reale con le ragazze
mica che gioia minchia siamo
chissà se questo deficiente c'è un tipo
che mi ha sparato in faccia
devo andare avanti ha soldi pedate
finché non muore su quanti siete
e morto morto vai vai vai vai veloce
flash line fatemi andare avanti ancora
non ho capito dove sto andando e brahms
brainiac figlio di tua madre non ti ho
visto un coltello
ragazzi se volete vi faccio un panino e
trova la stanza di generatori e
distruggi tutta la corrente come faccio
ah ok con lo sparato a caso va bene
ingiusto celo celo celo dio ma perche
tino listino bottiglia la minchia
salve mi dispiace volevo fare una zuppa
di zombies avevo voglia
scappa dal bunker prima che esploda
fantastico bella sta news
magari qualcun altro che mi spara
addosso nel mentre perfetto veloce ok ce
l'ho fatta poi ci sono steve zombie che
non si capisce chi siano però io sono
uscito tutto tranquilli e non si gira
neanche perché i veri uomini non
guardano le esplosioni giusto oddio case
spiderman piazza e questo può così come
qualche suo successo quale motivo il
bello è che è sceso tutto e cazzuto che
faceva spiderman è poi esploso che bello
lo scenario sembra tipo della sua base
cioè per essere un gioco indie ragazzi
tanta roba non pensavo a una giardiniera
quella che sta piantando le aiuole salve
lei non è un giardiniere questo
programma è bello si fa una dieta fai
come lei si vegana demaniale armetta che
ho fatto ragazzi ancora uno zombie per
terra ma chissene foto lo uccido chi è
perché ci deve essere c'è questo laddove
riuscito ma perché la gente esce dal
terreno ora affanculo una bambina che
farina
ciao tesoro e mi spiace poi all'ospedale
ragazza devi fare un ospedale vi curarti
guarda quella che beve il vino tesoro
non ama tranquilla io mi sto solo
spappolando degli zombie a caso tu
tranquilla bevi tranquillo offre mina
cena è quando arrivò mi raccomando non
lasciare che se io farei galantuomo fai
tu la galante donna veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce l'ospedale quante
grosso qualcosa dai ho finito i colpi
già fatta non ha neanche capito che
scazzi ci dobbiamo fare all'ospedale
però è tutto cazzuto lui che entra media
manco fosse rambo però va bene ma se
l'ho capito adesso che questo non è
affatto in computer grafica questo è un
filmato vero che sta gente se firmata
sul serio e si è messa nel videogioco di
geniale
ok un cazzo c'è gente appeso al muro non
capito hai voglia di bere un bicchiere
di vino mentre mi vedi squartare ste
persone appesa al muro
quello saltato il mio gol come ha fatto
a 26 dombi vite parallele fatemi farmi
capire
una seriamente sono pagate in mano vi
giuro ma avevo tanto è che le ragazzine
che possa concludere qui l'episodio è
strano come gioco è mai abbattuto
proprio le tette valgono tutto il video
cosa è subito piaciuta sono un commento
non mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
cosa invidio tornando iscrizione stasera
si discute ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze